hello everyone and welcome back to the
speed chess championship
finals we said that we were going to
cover uh at least one more game and a
lot of you said that you guys would want
to see a game where maxime won one game
now i'm not saying this is such a game
but i'm also not saying it's not so uh
without further ado uh let's check it
out as
it's as the title suggests uh it it
doesn't get
any better than this uh in in such a
short time format so
hikaru with the white pieces opens with
the knight to f3
and some of you are maybe wondering but
how is it even possible that they would
be able to play
such a game let's say 30 40 moves with
one minute on the clock
also with a one second increment and
play uh
such perfect moves well this game in
fact it's uh
for the first 15 moves basically it's uh
it's
theory so it's uh moves that have
already been played before
and both of them know it so uh by for
for the first let's say 15 moves they
are only gaining time
not actually losing time uh but we're
gonna we're gonna get back to that so
hikaru opens with
knight to f3 the the retti opening and
here c5
sort of uh inviting white to shift to uh
to a sicilian defense if white uh
not there but if white goes e4 we kind
of shift to
back to the sicilian but here just b3
hikaru
not interested in playing the sicilian
uh we have
knight to f6 and now bishop to b2
the bishop to this beautiful diagonal we
have e6 preparing to
uh grab more space in the center with d5
and
e3 uh by hikar with bishop to e7
and now d4 striking in the center and b6
uh maxim also wants to get his light
square bishop to this diagonal
bishop to d3 and now bishop to b7 and
here hikaru castles
and finally d5 so the setup has been
completed
knight beat to d2 both players have to
continue development
knight b to d7 and c4 now
and this has all been played before so
there is absolutely nothing new here
plenty of games in the database uh where
where this has been played and of course
both hikaru and the maxim know this
so here we have castles by maxime and
queen to e2 now developing the queen
connecting rooks
uh and here uh we have the first capture
of the game c captures on d4
knight captures on d4 and now the c5
square has been vacated for the
black knight and here knight to c5
attacking the bishop here
so bishop back to c2 hikaru of course
wants to keep his bishop
pair as it's so very nicely slicing over
to the king side
and now d captures on c4 we have knight
captures and the queen to d5 so up until
this point
this is uh all known and uh both players
i imagine do know them
or or know it or maybe they just played
the
the absolute best without knowing uh
the the previously established theory
but okay here now we have this queen
bishop battery threatening queen
captures on g2 checkmate
and of course he cower defends this with
f3 and here
there is uh there are a couple of games
in the database that reached
this exact same position uh most notable
one is uh
kramnik versus the reason where bishop
the a6 was played
uh and the kramnik was able to win the
game with the white pieces but here we
have rook
f2d8 which is uh one of the top engine
moves so i
imagine uh maxime was very well prepared
for this
so here and of course the as of move uh
14 we have a completely new game
so rook after d1 hikaru also brings the
rook into the game and
now comes queen back to h5 you don't
want your queen aligned with the rook
here and also since uh
the f3 pawn has been played this uh
queen bishop battery isn't doing all
that much so queen back to h5
and now uh well he could finish
development with rook to c1
uh uh hikaru first kicks the knight away
there aren't all that many great squares
for this knight uh so
he shifts it over back to uh to d7 we
have
a3 now uh adding more more defense to
the b
for pawn and now rook ate the c8 black
pretty much finishes development and now
uh white doesn't wanted this bishop to
be on c2 could be a problem in the
future
so he shifts it to b3 and now we could
have some
action happening here on e6 uh so you
have to be careful
so bishop to d5 now putting pressure on
the knight here and
rook ate the c1 we could say that white
also finished his
development with this uh move so knight
to f8
uh maxine prepares to shift to the
knight over to the g6 also adds more
defense to the e6 pawn and here
e4 charging that bishop we have bishop
back to b7
and now comes knight the e5 and this is
a very
uh very uh sneaky idea uh by hikaru
hikaru's point is that uh
well if queen captures uh then we get
something very nice here if queen
captures
knight to f5 is just uh awesome for
white
uh because the bishop on e7 is under
attack and also the queen on e5 is under
attack and even if we trade everything
with temple
so rook captures on d1 with check queen
captures rook capture sandy one with
check uh we don't capture with the queen
but first a nice uh in between move a
nice fishing suit
uh knight captures an e7 with check king
h8 and only then
uh we we recapture so we either uh
capture here and leave the queens on the
board or we could go straight for the
end game with captures captures with
check and bishop capture so now same
amount of pawns same amount of pieces
however
white does have the bishop pair and in
an open game with pawns on both sides of
the board
uh the bishop pair will will be stronger
so this is what hikaru had in mind but
maksim had something else in mind
and it's uh it's a beautiful idea the
absolute best so i imagine this was
also uh somewhere you know in in nvl's
notes
so feel free to pause the video and find
the absolute best move for black here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
bishop to d6 idea but not bishop to d6
just yet first we have to trade rooks
rook captures on c1 rook captures on c1
and only now bishop to d6 and now
there's a big problem for white
because the knight is hanging and you
cannot move the knight if you move the
knight
then queen captures an h2 is happening
so you have to play something else
now there are two choices here basically
you go for f4 and then you play this
terrible end game after captures
captures and the knight captures on e4
black just grabs a pawn and the white
will white will simply struggle
uh and it's it it's a bad end game for
white so instead
maxine uh sorry hikaru tried to hold on
to everything he played knight to beat
the c6 now the two knights are defending
each other
but maxine just plays bishop captures on
c6 and this is
the the absolute correct move because
again if knight captures
uh then again we have some action here
and
it's not much better if you capture with
the rook than just the bishop captures
here
and it's a problem bishop captures on e5
queen captures on e5
and uh well you're just down too much
material
so here he first played the g4 attacks
maxim's queen and now you don't have to
worry about
this uh queen captures on h2
but here maxine plays again a beautiful
bishop to b5 move
now getting uh his bishop away from the
c6 square where it was a target
and now the whole point of this is that
uh well you either again trade queens
and play a worse end game after captures
and captures
or you play bush queen captures on b5
and this is exactly what maxim wanted
but now the queen
on b5 very important is on a terrible
square because the queen is
undefended so here uh queen to h6
and now uh there are simply too many
threats here
queen to e3 check will be a terrible
threat later you can capture the knight
to bring the rook into the game
and very quickly checkmate the white
king so hikaru has to defend against
this
he played rook to e1 but it's not much
better
knight to g6 brings yet another attacker
to the e5 square and again
this knight can never move so rook to e2
was played
finally the h2 pawn is defended but now
it is far too late for such things
uh bishop captures and e5 is played and
there's nothing to be done here we have
bishop captures on e5
and now the whole point of queen being
undefended on b5
queen to g5 uh and it was in this
position on move 28 that hikaru nakamura
resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
there's a double attack on the bishop
you cannot defend the bishop any more
times and if the bishop moves of course
just queen captures queen so this is one
one
very uh rare occasion where a bullet
game is played
to such perfection as uh like it was
pretty much 15 moves of
pure theory and then maxime showed that
he he had a much better preparation in
this line
and we just had this well incredibly
high quality game
for such a short time format uh but yeah
uh this is one of the games that maksim
won in the bullet section but
then uh after hikaru got his streak like
we said seven and a half points out of
eight it was just uh
it was just a massacre uh but yeah
amazing game by max team so i i do hope
you guys enjoyed it as you requested one
of the games that maxim won and i
thought this was
the nicest one it was it's just um
you know very very enjoyable to watch
such uh
such you know brilliant play
but yeah uh once again i do hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank uh
thomas keller
matthew tobit josh cometh peter mazurak
and bradley cashio for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and uh i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh also the russian championship is
happening so we might
check out some of the games from there
if you have any of your favorite
dudes hashtag suggestion so thank you
all i will see you soon and
have an excellent start of your week